in the chinese city of xi'an people have
been taking to social media to complain
they've run out of food because of a
major lockdown
authorities say however that volunteers
are now delivering supplies to people's
homes and just one family member per
household is allowed to go out to buy
groceries otherwise and not more than
once every three days
china has adopted a zero tolerance
policy towards covert 19 infections
which could be a challenge when it hosts
the winter olympics in february
and correspondent fabian kretschmer
joins us now from beijing for more uh
fabian many of the 13 million people
living in xiang said they are struggling
to find enough food but beijing says
there's enough so what's going on
yeah it's really crucial to talk to as
many local residents because
yeah they will give you quite a
different picture compared to what's
been reported in state media
the people from xi'an that i talked to
some of them they are receiving um food
deliveries by the government many others
however don't and what they are doing is
they rely on
their neighborhood for example with
their neighbors they form chat groups
and then share cooking spices eggs meat
etc so um they rely on themselves um
however most vulnerable are the people
who who live quite underprivileged for
example the migrant workers or um people
who don't have a refrigerator
at home to store food and they are of
course most affected but compared to the
lockdown last year in wuhan and there's
no panic and it's relatively orderly
and um what is fabian china doing to
prevent the spread of the omicron
variant that's striking it the entire
planet
well they already have
one of the most severe restrictions in
place
the borders are de facto closed even for
long-term residents it's not easy to get
in and outside of the country
and when you do and come back then
immediately at the airport you're
carried to a centralized hotel
quarantine get tested um every day and
then stay there for two to three weeks
and um
that doesn't um make sure that uh there
cannot be any local infections as we see
now but um the government has to stick
to their recipe of lockdowns and mass
testing because
the only approved vaccines the chinese
ones don't seem to help
in terms of protecting from omicron
and just to return to the people of
xi'an is there any end to the lockdown
in sight
yeah um health experts tell me both from
inside china and outside china that um
probably the infection cluster will be
under control a maximum by february
because the restrictions are really very
severe however that doesn't mean that um
yeah there will be a lo another local
infection cluster anytime soon
okay dws favren kretschmer in beijing
thanks so much for that insight
you